في شرق وشمال الشرقي سوريا حيث تسيطر ما
يعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تتركز معظم
ثروتي النفط والغازي في سوريا واستنادا
الى تقرير لوزاره النفط التابعه للنظام
السوري في اغسطس ابا الماضي من القوات
الامريكيه وما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تستوليان يوميا على 66,000
برميل لنفنا من حقول المنطقه الشرقيه في
حين ان لا ارقام دقيقه عن حجم الانتاج
الفعلي لتلك الحقول تصدر عن المسلحين
الاكراد سيطرت ما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه على تلك المنشات الحيويه بعد
معارك مع مسلح تنظيم الدوله خلال عام 2017
و 2018
وتقيم القوات الامريكيه قواعد لها في بعض
تلك المنشات حقنا العمر والتنك النفطياني
بالريف دير الزور هما من اكبر حقول النفط
في سوريا كما توجد ابار النفطيه صغيره في
الرقه اما في محافظه الحسكه توجد بها حقول
الرميلان والهول اضافه الى عشرات الابار
النف كما توجد في نفس مناطق سيطره ما يعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه حقول ضخمه للغاز
ابرزها منشات كونكو بريف دير الزور وهي
اكبر حقل للغاز في سوريا اضافه الى حقل
الشبيسه والسويديه بريف الحسكه
[موسيقى]